[Musique]
l'amélioration des [ __ ] avait quant à lui
est inconnu nous lever entre la photo le
tendu la main à la main
bravo champion
et john ware apprennent à leurs gardes
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui
[Musique]
ce que ma caméra tu as manqué trois soit
à l'aise quand un jour tu sens vraiment
la 58 trop facile qui sans pleurer un
quasiment vraiment au score voilà je me
remets c'est bientôt de meilleures notes
alors se remettre au goût du jour la
voix d'amy cher
[Musique]
quoi
et la deuxième partie elle va parler
essentiellement de chocolat non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je lui déteste je le déteste mais
comment être comme en général après
terre comme j'étais fort
hanouna la vérité je savais faire du
salon ménages composés chacun d'entre
eux
[Musique]
à ce jour
ah oui
on ne sait pas qui est intacte
[Musique]
mais personne n'a jamais joué
ça
[Musique]
votre visite et la 5ème minute son
perçant
dans la note en réponse à cannes il ya
une boum dans ma loge un caddie mélange
pour les merveilles
[Musique]
il a quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
oh